chechnya we've all heard about it more
or less from the war in the 90s to its
present master father ramzan khadirov
who has a lot of weirdness to sell
i wanted to ask you about the alleged
roundup abduction and
torture of of gay men in the republic
um
what mr president do you want to to say
about that
up to the chechen soldiers enlisted
today in ukraine in the 90s chechnya had
become a veritable hell on earth
in its current state it's one of the 22
republics that make up the russian
federation but until a few decades ago
the situation was far more complex than
this oh my goodness today we're going to
try to simplify it to the bone and to do
that i try to start with my favorite
teacher geography located on the
northern slope of the great caucasus
mountain range the chechen republic
covers 15 600 square kilometers and is
included in the north cocos federal
district of russia along with it are
from west to east the karachi charcoal
republic cabardino valkaria north
ossetia alania ingushetia and dagestan
the caucuses massive as some of the most
inaccessible mountain valleys and high
altitude grasslands in the world and
this has certainly been an advantage for
the peoples of the area providing them
with good defense from invasions from
both north and south as for the churches
they are one of the most ancient
indigenous peoples of the caucasus in
the language they call themselves nokci
and in russian documents they appear for
the first time around the year 1500.
although part of the russian federation
the chechens have little in common with
the russians they speak a completely
different language a caucasian language
not slavic and they practice sunny islam
and not the orthodox christianity so
dear to the old patriarch cereal unlike
dagestan where the mullahs who spoke
arabic and persian had been spreading
the word of the prophet for centuries
islam in chechnya arrived quite late
also thanks to the mountain ranges only
in the 19th century thanks to imam
shamil leader and reference point for
all caucasian people in the resistance
against the russians as you can well
imagine caucasus is a mess the chechens
are not the only people in this area of
course there we have circassians
georgians abrahasians others nugai
ossetians cabardians armenians turks
azerbaijanis 50 000 greek speakers and
even some descendants from mongolia the
comics and we didn't even mention all of
them well just imagine how much peace
there can be with such a mixture of
different peoples in a mountainous space
that stretches 1200 kilometers and
across four nations there is russia
georgia armenia and azerbaijan and just
note that these four nations do not like
each other very much with some
exceptions of course for example
georgians cannot stand the russians
armenians can't tolerate the
azerbaijanis and vice versa while the
russians would like to have their cake
and eat it with everyone except with the
georgians to hell with the georgians
coal coasters and war are like natural
brothers the last recorded war in the
history of kokasus is just 28 years away
from us the first contacts between
chechens and slavic peoples took place
in the 12th century and for ages
chechens would base their identity in
oppositions first to the tsarist russia
and then to the soviets therefore it
should not be surprising that chechen
culture glorifies the idea of warriors
who defend their land with weapons and
bravery even today the image of the
strong man is rooted in the chechen
mentality just think of the videos that
the current leader khadirov posts on his
instagram
kadiro's
let's take a map from the 1600s to get
an idea at the end of the 17th century
the russians arts tried to open a window
on the mediterranean starting from the
black sea and the dardanelle strait
controlled by the ottoman empire the
expansion into the caucasus was
motivated by the desire to consolidate
their presence on the black sea however
in their advance the troops of peter the
great and later catherine ii were
overwhelmed by the unusual resistance of
the caucasian people of course
insurrections didn't lack that of
shaikhman surushurma in the late 1700s
or that of imam shamil in the mid-1800s
were just two of many examples the
resistance of the chechens and the
peoples of the caucasus was based on
three common elements islam the desire
for independence and the similarity of
languages that allowed the caucasian
peoples to communicate with each other
and fear much closer than the slavic
foreigners the russian writer tolstoy
knew kokosus very well and he himself as
reported in his book chad murat greatly
admired the chechens for their fierce
determination in resisting that star
forces not even the annexation to the
russian empire in 1873 quenched their
thirst for independence indeed even
under the soviet regime the caucasian's
resistance showed up several times in
violent riots over two decades between
1917 and 1937
up to the point that for three years
chechnya dagestan and ingoshazia became
independent from russian control stalin
who in the meantime had come to power
didn't like all that turmoil and broads
by forced the three republics under his
control being himself a georgian stalin
knew very well the mechanisms that
animated caucuses the strategy that he
adopted to unhinge this mechanism was
the usual one from the time of the
romans divide and rule let's make
another example of this tactic the
krachais and the balkars people speak
the same language a language of turkish
origin stalin created on the one hand
the socialist republic of karachi
circassia where the karachis were moved
along with the circassian people who
don't speak a turkish language but a
caucasian one and on the other hand he
created the socialist republic of
cabardino balkaria where he sorted the
other turkish people the bulkers along
with the cowboys and other people
speaking a caucasian language these
divisions ended up crushing the culture
and tribal structure of the various
ethnic groups the same stalin did with
false accusations as in the case of
world war ii under the pretext of
chechen collaboration with the german
army a falsehood that never happened
stalin took the opportunity to deport in
a single night in february 44 almost
half a million chechens to siberia and
kazakhstan name of the operation lentil
about hundred thousand chechens died
during the deportation only 1957 under
khrushchev chechens would be allowed to
return to their homeland in the
autonomous soviet socialist republic of
chechnya in gucettia if this all sounds
to you like a big mess it is
nevertheless the majority of the
population in the republic this time the
russian-speaking one that had come after
stalin's deportation caused great
problems for all those chechens who had
returned from siberia but since we don't
want this video to last for ages let's
just go back to the year before i come
to experience this beautiful world
1991
with the end of the ussr all former
soviet republics chose the path of
independence of course despite the
referendum on its preservation that had
clearly shown that 77 percent of soviets
were still in favor of maintaining the
union the autonomous republics of the
caucasus were also faced with a choice
independence or to stay attached with
mother russia the only one to follow the
idea of independence was from the
beginning chechnya ingushetia an old
general the soviet army jahar dutyev who
was elected president of the republic in
1991 pushed it in that direction with 13
years of exile in kazakhstan dudayev had
become the first chechen to become
general of the soviet air force
appointed commander of the heavy bomber
division in estonia the detail that
duday was in charge of a division
responsible for nuclear strikes
suggested that soviet authorities
considered his loyalty beyond any
question yet with the breakaway of
estonia 1991 the dayab retired from the
army and returned to chechnya
rediscovering himself as a strongly
nationalist politician taking advantage
of the disintegration of the ussr dudai
ever proclaimed chechnya's independence
there was an alcoholic issue yeltsin
for the russian president and his
administration the stakes in chechnya
and the entire north koreas were very
high and for three reasons first of all
oil in 1991 chechnya was in fact on the
root of the gas and oil pipelines that
connected the caspian sea and the black
sea certainly not a small matter in
economic terms then there was the
geopolitical questions moscow wanted to
avoid any power struggle in its
southernmost provinces this was an
attempt to make the west understand that
despite the collapse of the ussr the
russians era of influencing the
so-called near abroad had remained
unchanged and finally there was the
factor of stability it was necessary to
preserve the legacy of the imperial
tsarist conquest and especially the
soviet legacy of military bases still
present there all of this was done to
maintain a firm grip in a vital buffer
zone between georgia armenia and
azerbaijan therefore according to
russian logic chechen independence was
unacceptable breaking away from chechnya
and returning to the russian federation
was ingushetia which formally broke away
in december 1992 at that point of all
the former autonomous republics only
chechnya was left to challenge the
central power in moscow today was
convinced that the russian wouldn't
waste blood and money which was already
lacking in russia to bring the caucasian
rebels back into the fort however it
would realize to be profoundly mistaken
in the summer of 1994 the political
situation in grozny the chechen capital
worsened
and we called
was opposed by pro-russian
parliamentarians who were supported by
the kremlin through an economic embargo
a strong disinformation campaign and
armed attacks in the capital with the
first signs of chechen resistance on
december 1994 yeltsin was forced to
mobilize the army to restore what he
called the federal order it was the
beginning of the first chechen war a war
that would see one of the harshest
bombings since the one in dresden in
1945 and a war in which the russians
would experience at first hand a famous
caucasian motto that to defeat the
chechen you need another chechen on
paper the russians had all the
advantages on their side starting with
an army of more than 2 million men an
army that however was formed by quite
obsolete means and by soldiers who since
the end of the war in afghanistan hadn't
received an up-to-date training as a
consequence the russian infantry found
itself displaced when faced with a type
of combat to be adopted in chechnya on
one side the high-intensity close combat
in the urban spaces of grozny and on the
other side the lack of effective command
only left room for improvisation not all
of them proved to be incapable of course
among those who stood out were the
spatznets the russian elite corpse and
the vdv the airborne troops the russians
assumed that the capture of grozny would
mean the end of the war but the chechens
anticipated the moves placing three
defensive rings around the city and
turning it into a fortified nest with
land attacks being repelled by the
chechens who had no problems using
civilians as human shields the russians
increased their artillery attacks on the
city eventually devastating it with
bombing raids within a month what
remains of the capital fell into their
hands the fellow grozny was followed by
the flight of chechen soldiers into the
mountains and the discovery of thousands
of bodies estimated to be more than 35
000. the usce would describe that
bloodbath as an unthinkable catastrophe
when in april 1996 the head of the
chechen republic the diet was
intercepted by the russians and killed
with the guided missile the resistance
passed into the hands of his successor
another secessionist general azlan
mashadov the first thing mashadov did
was to launch a second assault on grozny
this time occupied by the russians this
kinda reminds me when a thief enters the
store only to be locked from the outside
by the owner with several thousand
russian soldiers ending up has hostages
of the chechen forces machado managed to
negotiate a temporary peace agreement
signed directly in dagestan in kazaburt
that agreement marked the momentary
victory for the about fifteen thousand
separatists but the balance of the war
was already devastating over one hundred
thousand dead nearly ten percent of the
chechen population while nearly two
hundred thousand of chechens were
refugees in afghanistan in essence in
the span of just two years more than a
third of the chechen population was
either six feet under or displaced the
regional economy was devastated and the
country had become a no man's land and
peace didn't mean friendship and only
served to freeze the church and
sovereignty the russians refused to pay
for war operations as well as for the
revenues from the passage of oil and gas
pipelines on the contrary they started
the project of another oil pipeline to
bypass chechnya altogether the baku
novoroysk pipeline this fluctuating
situation favored the development of two
phenomena in the country the arrival of
radical sunny islam of wahhabi
inspiration and the increase in
organized crime the radicalization was
fostered by the flow of money coming
straight from saudi arabia while the
local underworld was supported by the
contacts that the chechen warlords had
with the russian mafia all of this
generated the dynamite box ready to
explode in three years between 1996 and
1999 more than 1 300 kidnappings of
politicians ambassadors and foreigners
were recorded and things became more
complicated when in the mid 1990s more
chechens who had fled abroad in the
previous decades began to return from
the middle east some of this especially
those from jordan became the links
between locals and middle eastern
salafist extremists these invited saudi
and al-qaeda-affiliated commander emir
katab to chechnya qatab had fought as a
warlord against the soviets in
afghanistan where among others he had
been around bin laden circles in 1995 he
entered chechnya pretending to be a
journalist and began training chechens
by distributing funding and weapons
supplied by al-qaeda through the saudis
katsab for his part made no effort to
conceal his real goal which wasn't
chechan independence but to raise a
general jihad throughout the north
caucasus drive out christian russia and
create an islamic caliphate all it
needed was a spark qatar along with his
independentist colleague shamir basayev
found this park in april 1999 in
neighboring dagestan where a certain
bagudin magomedov proclaimed himself
emir and declared jihad for the
liberation of the caucasus and the birth
of the islamic state of dagestan
[Music]
this pissed off the russians
indeed 1999 russia was no longer the
drunken rush of yeltsin and putin was
the first that needed a higher profile
triumph
chechnya seemed an excellent opportunity
to flex his muscle and empower the
government putin also wanted to
indirectly warn the nato bloc with that
intervention implying one thing that the
caucasus was still a russian affair
however the russian intervention in
dagestan was the pretext for the let us
say controversial explosion of a series
of bombs that tore apart some apartment
buildings in three cities moscow bouinax
and bolgodonsk according to sami could
have been a provocation organized by the
russian security agencies themselves
also because a similar device linked to
the russian secret services the fsb was
found by chance in the city of ryazan
the event was used by the kremlin to
declare war a second time on the
illegitimate chechen government the
support of the russian population
obviously traumatized by the attacks on
their borders was very wide instead of
the reckless frontal assault that had
characterized the first war this time
the russian strategy was based on a well
organized and methodical plan russia
sent 30 000 soldiers to the northern
borders of chechnya starting a
stranglehold from three points north
east and west in a few weeks another
twenty thousand men joined the
sprinter-like maneuver arriving at the
end of october at the gates of grozny
with the difference that this time the
internal areas of the country had been
completely neutralized in the first war
in fact the objective had been
exclusively the capital and to do so the
various warlords had been left in
control of the countryside between mass
graves filled with corpses men suspected
of being rebels and then shot in the
street and civilians reduced the
starvation the second war lasted nine
months
[Music]
grosney was declared liberated on
february 6 2000.
for the second time the capital had
become a crumbling city journalist anna
politkovskaya described it as a
monstrous conglomerate of burnt houses
ruins and graves but with some 80 000
federal soldiers still in the country
and the kremlin maintaining much tighter
control over the state media the second
war with more than 5 000 russian
soldiers killed didn't shock the russian
public opinion as much as the first
conflict then when moscow announced in
may 2000 that it would take direct
control of chechnya putin appointed
ahmad khadirov as interim head of the
local government khadirov was one of the
most prominent former rebels who had
deserted the independence coast to take
an oath to russia kadyrov had been a
major separatist during the first
chechen war but he had always criticized
the wahhabi extremism adopted by the new
generation of soldiers so much so that
he was viewed with suspicion by his
younger colleagues for this reason in
1991 when the war broke out he and his
son ramzan didn't think twice about
siding with a federal government in
moscow the two would have brought to
their side a large group of disorders
who then formed a paramilitary force
that still exists today the cadillopsi
the followers of kadyrov those soldiers
that today we see in the military
parades organized by ramzan or part of
this group cornered by this strange new
alliance the rebels began to adopt
hardline terrorist tactics in 2002 about
40 of them broke into the dubrov
cathedral in moscow taking 850 people as
of stage
after two days of unsuccessful
negotiations the russian spatznets
released a narcotic gas into the
building which not only neutralized the
attackers but also killed 117 hostages
two years later it was the turn of a
small town in north ossetia beslan on
the first day of the new school year
more than 1 000 people many of them
children were taken hostage by the
church and separatists on the third day
of siege the building was stormed by
russian forces and about 300 people lost
their lives in the clashes
[Music]
commenting on the tragedy of aslan putin
said we showed weakness and then weak
people paid the consequences
mizlan exacerbated the war against the
chechens in march 2003 the duma issued a
new constitution in which the chechen
republic was explicitly defined as an
integral part of the russian federation
and a few months later khadirov swore in
as the new president in the meantime the
rebel movement had become a shadow of
its former self leaders were killed one
after the other and the ranks of the
spartists had been considerably reduced
in the last years of the war and with it
the hope for a free chechnya khadirova
senior and khadirov jr took the place of
putin's federal forces and that was
enough to keep the situation under
control and with time the war ended
quietly without great upheaval when in
2007 ramzan khadirov replaced this
father who died following an explosion
claimed by shamil basayev large scale
operations were long over katab who
survived the mine explosion and a
machine gun blast in the stomach had
already died in march 2002 when an
undercover fsb agent delivered him a
letter soaked in nerve agent in march
2005 mascardov by then a general without
an army had been assassinated by the
federal forces in the town of tolstoy
yurt doku umarov who took the poison
chalice as new head of the resistant
movement in 2006 declared the formation
of the kokusu's emirate with the aim of
unifying the nationalist and jihadist
movements into one common organization
but this had no concrete results and he
too in 2014 died under still unclear
circumstances probably also from
poisoning poison is a very popular
weapon for the russians it wasn't until
2009 that the russian national
anti-terrorism committee declared the
military operation in chechnya over and
determined that the conditions for
normalizing social and political life in
the republic were in place the remaining
rebels were estimated to be 500
individuals all in the countryside
according to some they are still sleeper
cells but as long as kadyrov manages the
kremlin power from a distance it's
likely that no one will make serious
claims for his part kadirov is an
outspoken supporter of vladimir putin
who in turn has repaid his support by
making him a hero brusher khadirov
enjoys nowadays a level of freedom that
no other local leader in russia enjoys
in the name of his father ahmad a huge
mosque with 4 minards has been built in
a capital and a 435 meter skyscraper is
under construction
the akhmat tower project will consist of
a 435 meter high building with 102
levels above ground and an underground
level for parking planned with 1 billion
dollars we don't know who donated this
sum the motto is akhmat is power but we
will talk about kadyrov and his
disturbing social life maybe in another
video
[Music]
for the moment one thing is certain just
as the prospect of a russia without
putin would unmask the political vacuum
that could be created in the federation
the possibility of a chechnya without
khadirov risks turning time back 20
years ago and here the question arises
in the future will the dreams of
independence be stronger than the wide
autonomy that russians have granted to
the chechens in the meantime i thank you
for keeping me company until the end i
see you in the next video ciao